the horror people like oh wow that guy's
cool yeah but I'm not you know what
it's only when Wednesday and time you
know they're always like a week you know
or two weeks sometimes it's a year dying
time what Stan time yeah where do you
like more de crédito well you know
you're gonna die you know like when
David Bowie he was walking around but
there was like a two-week before he died
where he was in the hospital you know
that's bad time hmm there is it's not
I'm not trying to make a joke of it I'm
just saying there it probably is a week
a couple of days a month sometimes a
little longer time frame time frame well
you know it's you're falling apart
that's when you know you have your
family and your friends close are we
talking about this Thanksgiving we
should talk about Thanksgiving all right
but I'm not done talking about dial tone
I wear a tie time right all right I want
people to feel and also can I just say
that this is what makes me hope is the
next by the time I'm 18 by that time
that was pretty yeah baby
stop by the time I'm 80 okay your
child's gonna have so much fun
it's take the sound technology I think
there'll be new [ __ ] replicant to keep
me alive a little longer
oh no I think we in that they just did a
head transplant transplanted a head on a
different body basically like get out no
wait at the whole head yeah swear I
don't know I think enjoy better not be
[ __ ] Danish well they did a complete
head trip yeah they just put a head on a
different body let me ask you this this
is [ __ ] great news are you sure Bobby
what body do this is great news the
reason I'm stopping this I know what I
would do look at it I would find
a fifty year old boy right I have to be
Asian because I have an Asian face not
make it make it be do do for the Bible
black a bit a bit have a yellow face and
a black body yeah but you know what at
your time I feel like I'll be able to
figure it out like I have a tanning
thing just for my head if I don't black
body that's that's not considered black
face right if you have a black body and
a yellow face right and then you try to
tan your face for your I don't think
that that's racism
no it's your body now trying to match oh
my god this is great news big dick
finally I will say the it's the alleged
surgery yeah it was but done by a
Chinese surgeon but like every article
around where he's he said he had the
transplant it's everyone saying it's not
possible so there's no yeah Holly mean
okay if you think about how the spinal
cord attaches to your brain figure that
out beyond that you have to get every
single blood vessel correct every single
one that attaches this part of your body
in your head you said million he said
he's claiming that he has done it and he
will show the result what is the result
is it a talking human or is it like
Frankenstein where it's like the
person's like barely alive oh it's two
corpses he did it with two corpses so it
took two of them so we had to Franco but
they're dead they're dead but he's dead
he's gonna try it
they're dead but it's gonna work it's
gonna work it's gonna work
he's gotten them I believe or what about
this would a brain you think they'll do
to the brain what do you mean like a
brain should brain take somebody else's
bob bobbi's brain into someone else's
body you to your body I have no idea the
implications mm-hmm I mean I would you
do it oh yeah let's write this movie
would you do it oh yeah I will do it out
was about that I'd wait old towards the
end just in case they messed up but yeah
yeah I would be the first guy I wouldn't
be the first guy I'd be like the 300th
guy you gotta get in because if it you
got to get it early in because you gotta
take some risk on this
because if you don't get in early and
then everyone so it's gonna be so
expensive but if there's a little risk
of like we kind of there's been some
mishaps like you'll get 80% yeah I'll
get into that like rube have you seen
like boob jobs from the 80s
they're like literal rocks on the
woman's chest because they got in early
okay really really sad yeah so no I'm
disgusts me
I mean hope I mean how cool would that
be
what's your ideal body like in terms of
celebrity imagine dude imagine being
what it's like I wouldn't want to know
what's like to be white I'm so confused
but your head what if they [ __ ] like
they they they harvest a body
specifically so they take my DNA took
clone essentially they make a clone of
me 16 right and then they just put my
brain into my body so that everything
works everyone you know but just like a
23:5 I think you would be really you
would be really really confused and
there would be a lot of implications
because you have a certain awareness
your brain is like now hardwired to
already has experiences already has
memories right and it's memory of
yourself as of use and Asian man so you
put that in a white body you will have a
lot of like anxiety and a lot of freak
outs I think yeah looking in the mirror
and you see somebody else I would've
caught imagine i would you lost your i
thought of it makes me feel
claustrophobic now imagine they're like
the only one we have right now and I'm
gonna bout to die is George have you
like put your brain yeah yeah okay I'd
be like okay look at the mirror yeah
yeah I'm gonna die I'll take that I
wouldn't see your head transplanted
unlike Shaq's body how about this I
would love that
sweetie finally his head proportions
really portions are correct what if like
I get an accident and there
then they go we have a clone of George
yeah I put my brain in charge would you
still date me no whoa everything is
mangas okay this is whoa sorry but I
think that a lot of like George not
attractive but our codes don't match a
lot of the reason why I'm attracted to
you yeah is I like the way your skin
smells I like the way like everything
about your chemical makeup of your
actual vessel of a body is what I'm a
traffic you don't like my insides I do
like your brain but what I'm saying it
with George is like I don't think like
this is why no one's ever said that
about me I like the way you smell I I
genuinely love the way his skin smells
like his raw skin with no chemicals on
it it's my favorite but I've also been
with people who initially I found to be
attractive but when I've gotten naked
with them where I just don't like the
way they smell smell yeah and it's not
that they seem they have Bo cuz
sometimes I like I like the right kind
of be like I like his Bo down but I
don't like certain people might our
codes just don't match in a certain way
I'm like oh I don't know why that smell
bothers me would they could put your
brain in like a wolf now I would do that
what animal would you put my brain in
either Octomom done oh no but see yes
smart no octopus is not a pecks though I
would put my body in an apex predator
like probably like a shark or like an
orca yeah
killer whale you beat the ocean I'd be
in the ocean for sure or she was the
horse until lacunae McCune and then you
spray like water on me like that was for
me yeah my girl yeah yeah
I had to go deep water swimming - [ __ ]
you yeah yeah no no mammals we're sure
we are so you choose wolf though you
choose and the pretty good wolf swim dad
they might like but that makes sense
with your personality cuz you want to be
the leader for pack it's the whole
relationship that you you all have to
become wolves we're all wolves George
what animal if they could put your brain
in an animal what animal
I think bald eagle cuz you're protected
so you can go anywhere it's your brain
is so much bigger than them it'll be
weird to have this is Paul the eagle at
this gigantic head I see for you like a
roly poly it's got to be a [ __ ]
animal that you can put your brand does
it look weird yeah okay let's go bear
yeah the air is pretty cool now let me
ask you this if you have the brain do
they have vocal cords which you like a
wolf we hold a brain itself doesn't have
my brain right so I know how to speak
you just got me by Bobby yeah you can't
do the same you can't do the same sounds
but there's that dog no but what I'm
saying miss online that goes like whoa
yeah says I love you I was a wolf and I
was gonna say hello I wouldn't have the
right tools to say it I think you could
but keep in mind now you have a human
brain yeah exactly but your vocal cords
are not going to be able to you know
what I mean um what's the word with an A
no you know it's not gonna be able to
okay forget your tongue like as they get
to you like chimpanzees can't do it
can't make the correct sounds for all uh
all the words we have okay yeah
interesting accommodate it's not gonna
be able to accommodate your vocal cords
of a wolf will not accommodate your
brain capabilities of a human I don't
want to be a wolf then you know how was
the a word I would really get to be a
pit bull and there being a how about
this pit bull and you
purpose they go to it like that pound
mm-hmm right and you only cute too like
hot chicks and then they'll pick you up
but you don't say that you're a man
that'll be cool - that's some good are
you dumb
[Music]